i love those sounds but
other people may cringe when they hear
them hi my name is dr antonia webb
i am an orthopedic spine surgeon i've
seen
lots of injuries in my 11 years of
training to become an orthopedic spine
surgeon
being in iraq as a combat medic in
today's video
we're going to be going over some movie
scenes and reacting to some of the
injuries
that's pretty unlikely that that will
happen and
cause a significant injury my god
there's a vestibular oh protruding from
your back
their vertebrae is actually sticking
from their back that would be a pretty
morbid uh injury but in this scene here
the chiropractor that was trying to push
his vertebrae
back in place uh that usually doesn't
happen
there's a new phenomenon called the y
strap
where they put you in traction and just
pull on your spine
that's usually not what happens when
we're trying to push a vertebrae back in
place
when we see a bone especially a spine
sticking out someone's body
that patient most likely will not
survive
the survival rating of this one out of
10 just because
of the vertebrae that the chiropractor
saw sticking out of his back
that's a pretty hard fall i can't see
how
big of a fall that was but patients come
in after
sustaining falls usually we have
patients that come in they fall from
their roof
or they're up on a building doing
construction and then they fall
usually they land what's called this
kind of foosh injury
fall on outstretched hands when you're
landing like this
usually they come in with both of their
wrists that are usually broken
they have calcaneus fractures which is
the heel bone
uh sometimes when people land they land
on their feet
their heels and they they just crush
those bones
and they can have tibia fractures which
is your lower leg
we put him in what's called external
fixators to
stabilize that area of the bone until
the soft tissue kind of
swelling goes down so he would have most
likely had
injuries to his facial
bones mandible fracture lots of uh
different fractures and muscle skeletal
injuries
most likely rib fractures which are
pretty common you can have what's called
a pneumothorax
the rib fracture will actually puncture
the lung
requiring a chest tube which is a tube
that is put in the chest by general
surgeons
to reinflate the lung the areas that he
landed on the
tops of the roost the things that he hit
on the way down may have
braced him some but there's really no
correct way to fall
it's probably likely but he would
sustain a lot of injuries a patient
getting up and
walking from after something like this
is pretty low
[Music]
that's a pretty serious motor vehicle
collisions what we call an mvc
some patients are actually ejected from
their vehicle
this type of car accident where there's
a head-on collision
you can have injuries to your chest you
can have injuries to your wrists
to your aorta when there is a really
fast deceleration
of a moving object it can actually tear
your great vessels and these vessels can
bleed
really fast you can actually collect
two liters three liters of blood inside
your chest cavity within
minutes within seconds and this can be
very fatal
for a lot of patients who have these
injuries
luckily there's airbags with the you
know
help of seat belts a lot of injuries um
can be kind of mitigated but
this is a pretty serious accident where
patients will come in with multiple
injuries
polytrauma is what we call it this bone
here is called your
c2 or your dontoids can be a pretty
serious injury especially in a young
patient where the bone does not heal
an option is to put screws into their
that bone there or to place them in a
halo
so these are kind of metal rods and
clamps that we use to
place on the the head and patients will
actually wear this for up to eight to
twelve weeks
and sometimes these screws become loose
or they become infected
and they have to be replaced so that's
that's what he's doing uh this can be
pretty painful for a lot of patients and
uncomfortable
but we usually anesthetize or give them
some pain medications before
and then these bars and rods are used to
stabilize the spine the head and the
neck
until it hills so this is a pretty
realistic
but i think his survival chance is
pretty good at this point if he's
getting a halo
probably six out of ten
[Music]
he did have a gush of blood that came
from somewhere
i would imagine that it came from his
carotid artery maybe you do have a
vessel that's
on the inside of your neck here that if
you're
stabbed or that vessel is injured that
vessel can bleed
quite a bit and patients actually can
die just from
um if you don't hold pressure kind of
over that vessel but
this is a pretty fatal injury
your spinal cord is actually surrounded
by lots of ligaments it's surrounded by
the spinal column which is a
number of different bones that protect
the spinal cord you actually can get
stabbed
in the spinal cord itself and cause
some saying different various
neurological
injuries depending on the location of
the stab wound in the spinal cord is it
in the ventral portion of the spinal
cord which is the front part
is it in the posterior aspect that will
dictate
what neurologic presentation that
is seeing so the kidneys are in the back
but a little bit lower
uh near the l1 l2 region that can be
injured
your aorta is just off to the side of
the spine
if you have an injury or stab wound to
that that can be pretty fatal
you have to actually split the chest
open to actually
find that tear and try to repair it by
that time a lot of patients
will die from an injury like that but
this is a pretty
fatal injury that the chance of him
surviving this without
attention is probably really low two out
of ten
and you can see he's laying on the
ground there this is uh
a state of shock that a lot of patients
when they're
undergoing certain types of injuries or
trauma
your body goes in the state of shock and
you
basically are kind of in a fog you
really don't recall
kind of what's going on your body is
resorting all of your blood supply
all of your energy and your nutrients to
the
muscles and the um the the body parts
that need them to for that
fight-or-flight
response that people talk about we do
have other bones and
soft tissue skin that protects us from
outside
injuries but you can imagine
200 300 pounds that is laying on the
person or on top of a person that can
essentially just crush you
your heart your lungs your kidneys and
these things are pretty fragile
dogs cats snakes these can
cause a lot of injuries also when a lot
of the infections
that can be in like a cat's mouth when
they use their claws
to get inside of a joint
this can cause a lot of damage inside
the joint so as orthopedic surgeons
we would normally take this patient to
the operating room to wash out their
their wounds wash out their joints give
them antibiotics
tetanus most likely three out of ten
i like the extra added effect that she
landed
right on the bar stool on her neck you
know there's a lot of injuries that you
can sustain to your eye
to your facial structures you can
actually receive what's called a
epidural hematoma and these are blood
collections hematomas that collect
either on top of the dura which is the
kind of hard structure surrounding the
brain
or under the dura it's called a subdural
hematoma
and this when there's a collection of
blood can cause a lot of pressure on the
brain
that uh you know as you know the brain
is responsible for a lot of our
functions
like our thinking speech so it can
affect those things so
this is an injury that can be pretty
fatal there actually have been lots of
boxers who have died
from blows to their head
from these bleeds you do have some
vessels in your neck called your
vertebral arteries
that can be injured you can have
fractures in your neck from that fall
you may not hear the bone fractured in
your neck but the
the bigger larger bones you may hear
that you'll hear that snap
this scene is pretty realistic in terms
of the audio kind of quality or the
sounds
we hear these sounds a lot especially in
the er when a patient comes in and let's
say they
dislocated their hip usually in car
accidents when when their knees hit the
dashboard
and their their hip dislocates is
usually called a posterior hip
dislocation
in the er what we do as orthopedic
surgeons i will usually
stand on top of the patient on top of
their bed
and actually pull on their leg while
someone is pushing down
and you can actually hear that hip just
pop back and socket
it's a very gratifying feeling for
orthopedic surgeons especially me
i love those sounds but other people may
cringe when they hear them
i would say the survivor weight in this
is 8 out of 10
7 out of 10 depending on what type of
injuries what happens in her brain
to ensure that she doesn't have any
brain damage or
injuries in her brain that could be
deadly
[Music]
the chance of someone snapping their
back like this and surviving is
pretty slim the major vessels in your
body your aorta and your inferior vena
cava these things are pretty
fragile and when you take a lot of force
or when there's a lot of force applied
to the body
it can rip these vessels uh pretty
easily especially from a
height like this when her body is
snapped
that can actually tear and cause injury
to the
spinal cord and the nerves that are in
the back as well
i would imagine if she would have
survived
she most likely would have been
paralyzed or would have
sustained substantial damage i'm a big
spider-man fan i think
a better kind of option he didn't have
many
choices at this point would be to cast a
net and she fall into the net
where just this one web didn't actually
just pull on her spine and pull on her
body like that and she just
forcefully went back and kind of snapped
her back
um this is a unsurvivable injury
[Applause]
so this is another kind of bad injury we
call it an mvc rollover
these are pretty serious injuries and
sometimes they can be
quite fatal he is rolling in the
stretcher
through the hospital he most likely
would had a
cervical collar which is a collar that
is applied by the ems
personnel to stabilize the spine he
should have
a cervical collar on they should have
immobilized him before they
extricated him from the car
the seat belts are important as well as
the airbag the airbag can actually
cause injuries where it can fracture
your ribs
but it does protect you from the
steering well as well as being
ejected from the vehicle so you can have
injuries to your thorough racks to your
chest to your abdomen so a lot of these
patients
are receiving multiple imaging studies
such as a ct scan
to search for a lot of these injuries
when they come into the emergency room
it looks like he had injuries to
bilateral wrists you can see the
the gauze and the the wrapping that he
has
on his wrist at that point
the chance of survival looks like he's
awake
at this point his eye is the right eye
is open but the chance of survival
six out of ten
[Music]
how fast they were going from the
sky to actually landed on the ground it
looks like they slowed it down
quite a bit but i've been skydiving
before
i would have thought that the impact on
the ground would have been greater
usually patients they break their heel
bone
called your calcaneus and when this
happens it actually just crushes the
calcaneus crushes some other bones that
are in the
feet depending on the type of land
whether they're landing on their feet
whether they're landing on their hands
or their back
that will dictate what type of injuries
are sustained
the chance of them getting up and
walking is pretty low a lot of times we
have adrenaline
our flight or flight response is
activated and you have this adrenaline
after accidents or falls
and you can still get up and do things
but
you may be seriously injured so
this was most likely what happened in
this scene here i would
imagine kind of a tuck and roll type
fall where you're protecting your body
you're rolling and
hopefully that will minimize some of the
damage or injuries that you sustain
this is a survivable injury if it was
based off of this movie scene but if it
was in real life
and he had a greater impact on the
ground
the chance of survival would have been 6
out of 10 maybe
oh wow bowling ball just comes out of
nowhere just
hits him in the chest this is uh this
can be
a pretty serious injury as well the
injuries
could be anyway from facial trauma to
long bone injuries to injuries to their
soft tissues muscle skeletal
that bowling ball probably broke a
couple ribs when they hit him in the
chest right there
if someone did get hit in the head with
a bowing ball
that's a pretty heavy ball
that would have caused a lot of injury
to the
face itself to the brain jury so there's
really not much that
kind of surprises me at this point i had
a patient come in
after a airplane crash he had a small
airplane
he took it up and it crashed for some
reason he had multiple fractures
and had a lot of other bad injuries but
he was actually still talking to me when
i saw him in the
emergency room we've had attacks by
different metal objects brooms um
gunshot wounds explosions
i've seen it all i've seen a lot of bad
injuries a gentleman who came in
who had leg amputations
from a motorcycle accident his body was
on the stretcher and his legs both
legs were in the bag in the corner so
that's a
pretty typical day in the trauma
emergency room and as orthopedic
surgeons we treat
all of these patients surviving a
bowling ball of injury to the face when
it's going that fast is
pretty slim the areas that he landed on
the
tops of the roof the things that he hit
on the way down may have
braced him some but there's really no
correct way to fall